[Música]
ah
i
o qué picante que estuvo el té de x
comodoro rivadavia en su cuarta edición
impresionante la verdad
tremendo tremendo los oradores que hemos
tenido fantástico y me han dado mucho
material y ellos lo saben con los
coaches lo saben y los 12 oradores lo
saben
la verdad feliz de estar acá sabe que
usted sabía que este significa
tecnología entretenimiento de diseño
bueno en su cara sigla porque hablamos
de un montón de cosas acá hablamos de
ati dosis de finanzas de emprendedores
de transgénero de aceptación de trabajo
de educación de la crisis urbana de todo
hablamos acá somos como los morosos hay
que esto hay que hacerlo todos los meses
y medio complica este tremendo tremendo
usted recuerda que hace unos meses
estaban los medios a full con el tema de
los arrepentidos
bueno acá tenemos a la gorda arrepentida
mercedes olavarría que
[Aplausos]
la activa pasó de estar todo el día en
el sillón morfando fumando 20 puntos así
sastres y dijo no yo no quiero esto para
mi vida empezó al gimnasio y un vio un
cartel que dice del running y dijo bueno
voy a empezar a correr y empezó
corriendo media cuadra
tres cuadrillas cinco madridistas un
kilómetro 35 12 20 y 180 kilómetros en
las islas canarias
tremendo 3 y eso no es perseverancia
constancia yo no sé que la verdad muy
grosa en mercedes acá para ti
la verdad me dieron ganas de salir
corriendo
y otra que corría mucho que corría y
escapando no sé qué era paula sánchez
paula sánchez corría corría y corría
tanto material me dieron que ya me
olvidé todavía
paula contaba que tuvo el combo
adolescente bulimia anorexia depresión
intento de suicidio fatal y bueno que
fue superando crisis con la aceptación y
todo eso y dice que sobrevivió a sí
misma y la verdad hay que sobrevivir a
esa cabecita dios mío porque un aplauso
para paula
muy bien paula y la llegada de bruno a
su vida le cambió la cambió
completamente la existencia y hoy no
sólo trabaja para que bruno tenga una
mejor calidad de vida sino otras otras
otras familias con hijos fuera de norma
así que es un trabajo muy noble el que
hace pau la capa total
y hablando de
hablando de crisis las crisis de super
pabla paula me pongo a pensar en otros
dos oradores que hablaron de crisis
primero sebastián les habló sobre las
crisis y cómo son oportunidades nuevas
para las ciudades de mejorar muy buenos
muy buenos ejemplos que dio y otra que
habló de crisis fue silvia vega silvia
vega habló sobre como una crisis también
es una oportunidad de reinvención que es
el mejor camino para cuando las cosas no
salen como esperábamos lo que queda
reinventarte empezar de nuevo resetearme
y vamos andando
igual silvia que me dio tanta maneja el
ropero de sigo en el ropero y fotos del
rapero de la caída llaves ropero lindo
el ropero ocho pelotas y el carpintero y
la y bueno pero bien me hizo acordar la
película narnia contando ropero
[Aplausos]
esta es nuestra totalmente improvisados
no estudie un word durante toda la
madrugada
pensando ropero pienso el doctor mateo
fonseca que salió del closet cuando
tenía nueve años
no no me avisan del control que nunca
había entrado del closet marcano de una
mala memoria este
bueno mateus fonseca es es el
estereotipo del gay refinado que es alto
esbelto que esa piel tersa brillante no
lo es es es un muñeco que en el guacho
este es un que es un que en como de las
barbies y claro no es casual que su toda
su historia comienza con una muñeca y su
muñeco es como es como él es como el gel
moreno y con anteojos culo de botella
los accesorios se vende por separado
mateo nos enseñó que la estética no es
sólo una cuestión frívola sino que tiene
que ver con la salud con la autoestima y
que bueno hablo de que la belleza no es
lo que lo que no es algo así como
estético sino es lo que uno siente la
belleza es lo que uno siente y otra cosa
que dijo es que la belleza es una noción
abstracta
buena frase y hablando de abstractos yo
me remonto ha gustado fernández que
hablo de algo atrás trato que son como
son los pensamientos gustavo arrancó con
esto de los pensamientos de que hubiera
pensado el pensador que en realidad el
poeta que cuando pensaba que pensaría
que pienso cuando pienso ahí ya se me
trabó el hámster en la rodilla se me
corrió el coágulo así fue un acb y no lo
pude seguir mucho pero como muy bueno lo
que los vientos soplan para todos igual
sobre todo acá y que la vena hay que
orientarla y dijo dijo algo muy lindo
algo así como decir lo puedo creer lo
puedo crear me quedo con esa frase muy
buena este y bueno dijo dijo algo que me
es imposible no relacionarlo por lo
menos en mi cabeza que le va a pasar lo
mismo él habló de que él iba a
nombrarlos pero iba a llamar a los
pensamientos turistas interiores y
cuando dijo así turistas interiores yo
no podía pensar para de pensar los
parásitos de óscar porque obviamente me
me refiero
ad hoc arcense
para aportar
oscar jensen la verdad
es una apasionada de lo que hace lo
demuestra que hace 36 años que está
combatiendo le de acidosis
y bueno ha recorrido muchos lugares y él
tiene todas las herramientas para
terminar con esta problemática pero la
verdad que me las olvide todo porque yo
lo miraba y me perdí en sus ojos del
cielo
solo me lo miraba y ojos de cielo
y bueno y ahí me perdí igual unas frases
y dos cositas del powerpoint que tiro
que me dejaron pensando así tiki tiki
picando en el área que es 4 por día y 1
por semana
todo estimó
yo estimo que es una
el tipo que es una metáfora la vida
misma no la
este
y otra cosa adriana gusta korac y
enseguida estás ahí atenta no ya se
llama acordes hablando de pasión como no
relacionarlo con esteban núñez que es un
apasionado porque es la característica
principal de un emprendedor esteban yo
conocí en él un joven muy muy sensible
como un coach así pero el tipo usó la
parte más racional del cerebro para
crear una compañía de software y hoy
está varios países y engrosó actualmente
cuando él arrancó y contó que cuando le
preguntaron cómo había llegado a donde
había llegado se le puso la mente en
blanco como no sabía cómo yo no llego
hasta seis siempre sea dudar de todo lo
que decía o sea pero poca ya viste me me
desconecté un poco
igualmente si puede no nos contó que es
emprendedor cuando se enfrenta a la
mentira
que hablando de emprender soy yo eso sí
nací con sinapsis con las tres neuronas
que tengo hablando de emprender tuvimos
a daniela andrade que en su infancia
casi adolescencia tuvo que emprender un
camino muy solitario en principio y
bueno y fue duro como lo contaba y hoy
por él no está sola en su lucha y nos
contó sobre la temática del transgénero
y que lo importante que es el
acompañamiento familiar para un niño
transgénero buenísima la charla pero lo
que hace un paréntesis acaba muy
importante pues yo que soy muy reflexivo
yo pensaba no nosotros tenemos un grupo
de whatsapp de oradores ted y que pauta
vamos los ensayos
y ella decía buenas tardes a todos
yo pensé ahí no dije para no es casual
ella en realidad no se llama daniela
andrade se llama daniela andrada pero lo
cambio para que se apellido inclusivo
eso te saque las fichas de las villas
le voy a decir otra vez como 6 minutos
porque es inclusivo no
yo lo sé que no estoy solo en esto
porque se dice el lenguaje inclusivo y
no el lenguaje inclusive si todo anda
como los quieren no quieren confundir a
todos abajo
en el solitario camino que tuvo que
emprender daniela y no puedo parar de
relacionarlo con alberto que contaba que
las finanzas son como chicos que juegan
en el arenero en la plaza solos solo
juegan porque nadie quiere jugar con
ella porque es una nerd si no se quema
dijo y después cuando dijo algo de que
las finanzas o como las ex novias que
leen las cartas de
me parece muy bizarra la metáfora
y hay algo que me remonto mucho a mi
adolescencia concha pava en el periodo
del boliche que dijo el apalancamiento
ahí yo me acordé el apalancamiento yo lo
conocía hace
hace algunos años
alberto me hizo rememorar
y hablando de jugar que contaba alberto
que jugaban las finanzas no puedo dejar
de conectarlo con la charla de alejandro
melamed que habló de
el trabajo del futuro y el futuro del
trabajo es un gran juego de palabra
entonces yo ahí lo conecté porque sino
no sabía qué decir tremenda la charla
muy buena en la instrucción que nos dio
y bueno él con ese a pesar ese juego de
palabras que me quedó a mí yo sé que él
habló mucho de trabajo se ha posicionado
el trabajo también y otra apasionada del
trabajo es la obra lewin que nos habló
mucho sobre cómo motivar a los alumnos a
y laura arrancaste apreciando porque
todos entonces bien sabemos que hoy se
dice alumnes sí así que hay habla con la
compañera que tengan siendo un poquito
de lenguaje inclusivo este bueno
igualmente muy bueno escucharle el aura
y ahora quiero hacer una aclaración acá
o estoy pero ventilando como un testigo
falso
no es fácil estar acá en este escenario
resumiendo 12 charlas de 12 oradores no
es fácil
por qué
porque si si es fácil venir acá decir
ayer a recordar pero empecé a trotar y
ahora soy ultramaratonista y yo estaba
re loca pero con la aceptación ahora
estoy re en eje o o como me parezco al
abuelito de heidi ando con las ovejas
estudiando la casona y eso sí es fácil
porque usted hacer una charla
una calle y luego así
y bueno y yo pensaba en lo difícil que
es todo esto pero bueno antes que nada
quiero gracias a torres por haberme
convocado
y
para mí también es muy difícil estar acá
porque mi mamá me dijo me dice pozos muy
lindos y a la gente linda no se la tiene
en cuenta no se la toma en serio desde
entonces yo quiero que sepa que yo no
soy sólo una cara bonita y un cuerpo
tallado si yo soy actor bailarín
cantante poeta profesor de inglés de
teatro atleta abstemio y no fumaba
exagera un poco pero para que tenga el
concepto
que quiero destacar en todo esto la
verdad antes que nada quiero otro
aplauso para los 12 oradores y todo el
equipo
pero menos
y ahora qué
conocí un grupo de gente maravilloso
maravilloso a la hora que era era
esperar re manija el próximo ensayo
porque los quería ver y compartir la
verdad hermoso y me quedo con esta
reflexión que me acaba de bajar ha sido
una epifanía nada ensayado
además del amor y la pasión por lo que
hacemos
pongámoslo humor muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i